[Music]
this week we've got Google adblock class
is coming and a dad ad talk of the work
but when we pick up the word first story
google has announced that they will be
creating their own Google ad blocker
that will be launched in early 2018 does
that even make sense right because if
YouTube has ads and you choose part of
Google they're gonna block their own
[ __ ] probably for a price that's kind of
like watching TV and then the TV says
hey do you want to not see any of our
advertisements while you watch our free
show yeah yeah how does this work
all right so it sounds like it's gonna
be right but what they're saying is that
they are trying to block ads on sites
that have bad advertising experiences
for example like if you see these like
if you go on a website and then there's
an ad that has sound that automatically
starts playing oh hey I hate those so
much I cannot find where the source is
coming yeah and so throughout the whole
thing I'm looking for like I'll add and
I'm trying to click off or maybe it's
this [ __ ] website out of the 14 tabs
that I have and it's just like this
random music thing isn't it usually have
a little speaker on the tip that one
Safari not on like the chrome O'Reilly's
yeah they know my boy yeah because
that's the one feature I love about
Safari it doesn't get it okay
Safari is a piece of [ __ ] though good
job I don't even know what I use I guess
I use Chrome yeah I think he's chrome
yeah it's either Chrome Firefox or
that's not the Firefox no I use Chrome
and Safari Google is giving publishers
six months to prepare for this adblock
that they're gonna be implementing on
their Chrome on both desktop and mobile
so you're saying that this adblock will
be automatically
turned on for chrome they will be
blocking ads from sites that don't meet
the standards that they've already set
for ad so I liked you Google Chrome you
got my back 24/7 I don't like it when
they have an ad and it's like one of me
single Mormons and I'm like why
that's not even your supposed to
understand my cookies and [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] is this ad coming up
meet single Morgan Mormon yeah you don't
get those weird ads like it's like yeah
are you looking for like single Muslims
in your area I know we're like hey chat
try this
they theists dating site and I'm like
what yeah what's going on did I go on to
the wrong website or some [ __ ] it's so
weird though how all those ads like work
together down cuz you look up something
and then you go to a different page and
some of the things that you're looking
up is on that page and yeah it's a sign
from God that have to buy it
I'd be getting because I was on Amazon
looking at bugs and stuff and then I
left Amazon and then somehow it showed
up on my Instagram how the [ __ ] did that
happen yeah that's pretty crazy
everything is connected to each other it
is frightening they know yeah I don't
like that
I just keep I just keep wanting to spend
money that's why I need it I need a
unlimited supply that's why I need to
yeah this nerds are taking over the
world and they're tying everything
together you can't see that so we own a
company right uh and we're actually
going with that service so from a
consumer standpoint it's scary cuz
you're just like oh [ __ ] how do they
know and now it's on my Instagram but
from a business standpoint I wanted to
work for let's go I love it I only
wanted to work for us actually actually
makes me feel like the computer cares
about me though you've been watching
what I do my wife doesn't do that for me
I don't like that I'm in the market for
some wheels I wanna get some wheels for
the car and she won't like okay cool
awesome the other of the in omelette and
I'll go surf and there's a like these
wheels well I like these wheels would
you like the I'm not all
I got a friend online no one knows you
like your father discourage you
encourages your spending habits I'm
gonna shut him up
it brings it even advertisers more
expensive stuff I'm gonna shut you up
no I wanna know when is your baby due
September 2nd in a copy a week before or
a week after the third I said the third
last time you said oh the second never
matter it's a week before a week after
that's what the doctor said
so doesn't even matter the dates
arbitrary Blau it's not like a birthday
how much won the bet is not gonna happen
on 3rd she's gonna hold that watch watch
she's gonna dislike September pretty I'm
not coming up right it might be the
first it might be August cuz I was
trying to explain sir explain sir that
the date doesn't matter cuz the doctor
himself I know that then why don't you
can hold on to what dates because you
don't know it so I'm cuz the date
doesn't matter trying to prove that you
don't have one of the bananas in our
house gonna expire who gives a [ __ ]
exactly what is a common explode the
[ __ ] ass the baby's covered you think
you come in
oh no no because it's a play on the
winter is coming
Oh our bird is offering a new game of
thrones class oh it's so ridiculous
how like the Ivy League like the dopest
colleges you know the ones that have
like the most highest form of
intelligence they get the best classes
yeah cuz I remember one of them had like
DJing yeah that was a new thing yeah but
DJ yeah I had this like one arbitrary
major then a couple of my friends took
it was like International Studies or
something but literally was you take
anything when you graduate I had a class
and it was a sleeping class so we went
in and the first kind of April I
actually got to be I [ __ ] up the first
time and it's you there the first 10
minutes the
lights are off and she plays like that
waterfall sound and everyone knocks out
for ten minutes and then after we talk
about how her sleep has been and we
write uh we write like little journals
of if the roommates affected or sleep
and all that stuff it was a don't class
I'm saying like all these classes like
did you know you could major in karate
no where any college or the Ivy I think
it was a mass universe UMass Amherst
Amherst we met a student there that was
a karate major like damn doctor of
karate that's pretty sick I'm not a
master you're a doctor like is probably
gonna be very historical huh
probably the student that told us that
you could actually major in anything if
you come up with the curriculum and then
you present it's you like they're bored
you have to go okay cool that looks like
a four-year study you can major in
anything you want oh my god eating
leaders in the world the master of
eating everything study and for students
that followed a pre structured
curriculum and they killed it in that
they weren't really good entrepreneurs
they were assaulted workers though like
they didn't go off and do their own
things I don't I just want to be a
mighty fighter yeah I just want to have
fun why you got to put in the work gonna
act creator you don't deal with people
you just do your [ __ ] and now you make a
bank why do I I don't want to work I
wish I made flappy bird you're talking
to a person that wants I work cuz I want
dreams to happen yeah but if I just if I
had the option of just having my dreams
to happen that I wouldn't work I want to
do everything for free but for some
reason I get millions of dollars every
month it's like this let's say you want
to jump inside some cold water and take
a dip in the pool right do you want to
build the [ __ ] pool no no you just
want to go and jump in the pool that's
what I'm talking about I keep on
forgetting to buy lotto tickets man
I keep [ __ ] up set a reminder I know
a lot of ticket I just want I feel like
what we should do is steal money from a
different country and come back to the
you
Oh like history yep why are you guys
interested in this game of thrones class
yes yes yes sorry Game of Thrones fans
mm-hmm
yeah so they're saying that this wait
wait wait is it supposed to figure out
like let her finish Julia I'm just so
curious to ten minutes away I know the
one time she speaks you guys shudder I
know right you say what you want to say
you got just go ahead what's in this
course okay well it's not directly about
Game of Thrones all the sense that
you're thinking where it's like they're
gonna discuss the actual show and like
the theories that go beyond it no it's
not that the name of this course it's
called the real game of Thrones from
modern myths to medieval models so what
they're pretty much doing is that
they're taking the show and comparing it
to actual historical events or like
mythology that's dope
you know what's the interesting thing
about me so I love movies right and I
love film there's one thing that I will
always watch no matter how bad it is it
has anything to do with like medieval
fighting or like Greek mythology I don't
give a [ __ ] how bad the reviews are I'm
watching that [ __ ] like King Arthur Game
of Thrones is the same thing over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
Nas not over and over and over and over
and it changes like I watched the first
season but here's the thing like Game of
Thrones and all those type of shows they
are literally exact same formula for any
other show
it looks dope the fighting is great but
at the end of the day like after all
though all those shows four seasons and
you're pretty much done that's how it is
for me anyways I'm like I'm not cool off
of it like there's a lot of shows too
that I'll watch that I'll watch it all
the way through because I like like the
violence and I like the fighting is [ __ ]
bro you like It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia that [ __ ] is like the same
[ __ ] oh it's not
that show is crazy every episode is
[ __ ] weird as [ __ ] that's why I like
it because you can't it's like
unpredictable it's so [ __ ] weird
he's a predict above [ __ ] defending
your Game of Thrones you know the game
of Thrones they like copy the war of
fibrosis or something like that that's
what it's based off of yeah yeah they're
saying that this just like the series
the course is gonna be based on history
of Eurasia which it was from the years
400 to 1580 what the hell is a Eurasia
sits in Europe and Asia before I got
like the country's Lanza mmm topics are
War rivalry middle aged mythology and
religion and roles of women in those
times and they're saying so for like two
examples here is one of them is slavers
Bay the fighting pits it existed no so
it's a comparison to the real-life
[Music]
you've been there right yeah is it big
humongous so it was like a football
stadium so it's big enough where they
used to fill it up with water and they
had battleship wars inside whoa and this
isn't 1100s that's how advanced they
were I don't know they were crazy cuz
like they don't have no trucks and [ __ ]
they gotta bring water from little
caravans doing what other times but like
he got rid of so many or he made a bunch
of animals extinct because he just
wanted exotic animals to fight each
other or fight people like it was not
yeah yeah he was horrible how could you
blame wonder what would look like a dog
fight a tiger a tiger fighting a giraffe
or whatever and then I think they were
saying there's thousands of deaths per
day Wow the despotic leader dude that's
[ __ ] is there like a human fighter
and it's just like yeah exactly
thousands of porcupine and a cat would
look like I mean they were saying like
every day they had to read IgG the sand
cuz the blood would seep in 6 inches for
the whole thing and it's like a football
fields would have to take the top layer
of the sand throw it away because it
smelled like [ __ ] and put another six
like everybody just went there to watch
death all day long
dude they would buy all their favorite
fighters like merch that they were the
first ones to cream urchin dyzee oh so
you want to be like pathos oh yeah
happens oh well you should have his
helmet then yeah kids with a number one
like that
yeah like another comparison to real
life is like Cersei when she did her
naked walk of shame so apparently it was
inspired by a similar punishment of
mistress of King Edward the fourth after
King Richard the third took over and
they punished Jane Shore with the same
punishment shame shame shame
she made her walk around naked well no
not me I think she was in her underwear
but yeah as a similar punishment that
they did I feel like people back in a
day has some ugly-ass bodies because all
their pictures don't make me horny high
for a Last Story there's these group of
boys that they call themselves the boys
from Washington bunch of douche bags so
one of the guys because they was Dane he
posted a Craigslist ad seeking for a
barbecue dad Craigslist ad barbecue dad
what this says needed
generic father figure for barbecue
backyard barbecue and spoke any he just
want someone at cook oh he wanted to
rent a dead we read to dad I so sad
Craigslist ad BBQ dad why so they're
saying that a lot of the guys as dads
from this group they live far away and
in just this whole event so this is this
barbecue is the day before Father's Day
so they're just trying to have like a
nice get-together but they for some
reason they're saying that it just
makes us to invite their own dad's
that's what they're saying
let's just get up we all have dads
they're cool we don't have anything
against them but let's just get a fake
dad well it's because well I guess the
main reasons cuz they said a lot of them
are living far away but now since this
ad went viral they're saying that their
dads will attend this barbecue but
initially there were see because even if
they're far away they could have been
like hey Dad want to come okay and then
dad could have just came
yeah then I guess they wanted like I
don't know they might have just thought
it was better to just have no but the ad
it reads to interested individuals we
will be throwing a backyard barbecue on
June 17th to celebrate beer and each
other we range in age from 21 to 26 and
while most of us know how to operate a
grill none of us are prepared to fill
the role of barbecue dad that being said
we are in need of a generic father
figure from 4 p.m. to 8 p.m.
though you may say flirt the full
duration of the party duties include
grilling hamburgers and hot dogs while
drinking beer they're just being lazy
Brooke Burton is my favorite one
referred to all the attendees as big guy
Chiefs foreign champ etc once drinking
beer talk about dad things like
lawnmowers building your own deck Jimmy
Buffett etc funny also why dead yes that
are highly encouraged and then desired
experience is a minimum of 18 years of
experience as a father a minimum of 10
years grueling experience an
appreciation of an ice-cold beer on a
hot summer day and they're saying that
they can't pay that that's dad and money
but they can give him all the sorority
girls
sounds like a frat house you know like
they just want to have any excuse to
party but they don't want to do the work
so they're like let's just hire a dad
for the day and then they'll barbecue
for all of us and drink with us and he's
pleasant to be around
see this is an innate and it's not their
own dad the ancient frat is way
different if there was an Asian grilling
barbecue I need a father who's gonna
gamble and drink with his friends in the
garage and not pay attention to us we
need a grill or stirs frog legs that's a
rabbit [ __ ] yeah this is
same posted ad so he says that's all the
other guys didn't know like he posted
the ads he just sit on his own but
here's a picture of the group or some of
the guys I was like a sad town
that's so [ __ ] funny if I was there
bad nights all this I'll be like what
the [ __ ] dude I'm right here man I
could've cave like I would have paid for
the ticket like what the [ __ ] yeah well
apparently they did find their generic
barbecue dad but they're not saying who
he is or anything they're waiting for
the day of the barbecue but their dad
their actual dads are coming to now so
they're gonna have real dad plus fake
dad dad and then jump his ass and beat
him up yeah poser
wait the real [ __ ] dead [ __ ] do not
[ __ ] talk dog though yep we do go to
this barbecue yeah free food when I was
in college
[ __ ] yeah it sounds pretty fun hey guys
thanks for watching if you guys enjoyed
that episode please let us know in the
comments below and share your thoughts I
like this so much oh I wish they talked
about this and this just let us know in
the comments for more videos click right
up here
[Music]